joined now by the chief exec of off gem
Jonathan brilli Heights good to see you
good morning thanks for joining us on
the program we're saying that people
will be better off but they won't feel
better off of course will they well I
mean you've got to accept that we have
seen the most dramatic change in prices
in our history so the real price of
energy is above 3 200 pounds and
although government are paying part of
our bills we are still at the moment
paying two and a half thousand pounds a
year now there is good news that is
going down to 2074 so prices are falling
but you're right when you take away all
the government support that's finishing
things are still going to be tough for
many families this winter okay um how
have you managed to bring it down to
that well what we've seen
internationally is a dramatic fall in
the cost of energy that we all need to
heat our homes and to make sure that we
can power all the things we need to
power now because of those Falls the
price cap regulates the price and make
sure that those Falls in costs are
passed on to customers and that's why we
can make that change today
um this is for the winter of course
um how much for the summer I should say
forgive me for the summer what happens
when we go into winter time again well
look I mean with the market the way it
is it is very hard to predict how prices
are going to change when we look out
across the forward markets prices look
roughly steady compared to where they
are today but I wouldn't put too much
weight on that it could take a big
change either in the level of demand
that we have for example prices May well
fall but equally should something happen
prices could go up again what we can
guarantee is through the price cap is
that because we regulate the price we
are paying a fair price for the cost of
the energy that we need
say
2054. 74 2000 it makes a difference of
course
2074. just explain to our viewers uh
where that figure comes from because
obviously that's the average a lot of
people will pay more than that they will
and what we're describing there is the
average household so if you look across
the country take a typical household
they'll be paying about 2074 but if you
use more than average then yes your bill
will be higher and if you use less than
average your bill will be lower what it
does mean though is the same direction
of travel for everyone so about 20 of
our prices are coming down and as we say
the support from the government ends in
July when this news price cap comes in
um
what's your view on what will you said
you can't really tell us what's going to
happen in in the winter time but but
what's your view on whether the
government should potentially start to
offer more support again if the bills do
go up well we've got to bear in mind how
much support the government's put in
place so they've paid almost 1500 pounds
of all of our bills over the course of
this winter now that's a massive amount
of money of course absolutely right and
you know we in August last year we were
asking the government to do that our
perspective now is as we fenced a
different phase in the gas crisis we
should all be focusing our efforts on
those most vulnerable customers who are
going to continue to struggle so it's
not just for government it's for
government for us and the industry to
work together to make sure that
customers are looked after what
important references how much our energy
costs well the principal influence is
the cost of gas and the cost of
electricity that we buy now what we've
seen internationally since Russia
withdrew its gas from the market is a
dramatic increase in those prices what
we're beginning to see now is the market
respond by new ways to provide our gas
and our electricity and that's why
prices are beginning to come down so are
you saying that as long as the war
continues in Ukraine we are going to see
high prices well I think without a doubt
that is a principal Factor that's
causing the prices High to be high now
but what we are seeing now are other
sources of gas coming so we're seeing
frankly gas used to come in pipes
through Europe into into Europe and we
used to biogas from there we're now
seeing a lot more gas being transported
on boats so over time there will be new
Solutions well they're roughly the same
actually in terms of the cost of the
commodity so they're not dramatically
different the problem is is right now we
haven't got enough gas so people are
competing for a smaller amount than
everyone needs and what we'll see is
America and other places coming forward
with gas and prices coming down I was
surprised at how much gas we use
actually in the UK we seem to rely on
gas more than any other energy
um what are we going to do about that
long term well look we're all heating
our homes with gas right now so all of
us go home put our central heating on
that's gas and many of our sort of power
stations are also powered by gas the big
thing we need to do and the Secretary of
State pointed this out is to make our
entire system Cheaper by moving towards
net zero so if we have more Renewables
if we have more nuclear if we have more
new sources of power then prices overall
and costs overall We Believe will get to
a better place but that takes time and
that means building more infrastructure
to get ourselves there and in the
meantime we um probably about 80 of our
energy uses gas is that right so a very
large amount is is our use of gas and
that is because we use it to heat our
homes part of our industry and for part
of our electricity okay so while we look
at that
um what Renewables there might be we'll
have a look at our should we look at our
dashboard in a second if we've got it
but um before that what if you were
sitting down with the chancellor today
what would you say for the rest of the
year so what I'd say to the chancellor
is that the economy is in a better place
given in the energy sector so the energy
sector is stabilizing the other factor I
should mention is we are hoping to see
fixed price deals and competition
re-enter this market so customers can do
better but the message to everyone is
the same we all need to make sure we
redouble our efforts to focus on those
who are most vulnerable and need our
help so what would your advice be to
people
um right now should they look at a fixed
price deal or is it too early to do that
well I mean we're not seeing a huge
amount right now but I am hopeful in the
second half of the year that we will
begin to see good value fixed price
deals so I'd encourage every customer to
check make sure they know what they want
some of us like to fix our price some of
us like to take more of a chance within
the market but look at look into the
market and see if good value deals come
forward and we're hopeful that they will
in the second half of the year what do
you do at home so what do I do I I have
always switched supplier when I can so
it's been a different Circumstance the
last couple of years but I always switch
supplier I always look into the market
to see the best deal for me now that for
me is not just about price that's about
the service I get and that's also about
the sort of tariffs I might want to sign
up to in the future so there's a number
of factors I look at but yes I'm an
active switcher in the market okay so
2074 from July but that could go up
again come the winter time or go down we
just don't know
it's good to see you thanks again on the
program